the funeral for an unarmed black man
shot and killed by a white female police
officer in Oklahoma will be Saturday
Terrence Crutcher died Friday after
police responded to a report of a
stalled vehicle protesters now on
officer Betty Shelby to be fired and
arrested the state's governor called
video of the shooting troubling Manuel
bohorquez is outside the Tulsa County
District Courthouse with new
developments on this med well good
morning good morning attorneys for
Terrans crushers family said he did not
pose an imminent threat to officers when
he was shot they are disputing the
allegation that he tried to reach inside
his vehicle and hammered home the point
that no weapon was found inside that
stalled SUV all right Betty Jo where you
at Terrence crunchers sport utility
vehicle was idling in the middle of a
Tulsa Road Friday night he's got his
hand stuck there for now his hands were
up and he was walking this guy still
walking tulsa police said Crutcher
failed to obey officers commands and
tried to reach inside his vehicle the 40
year old father of four was tased by one
officer than shot by another this is
clearly a case of excessive force in an
attempt to refute the police
department's reason for deadly force
attorney Benjamin Crump says enlarged
still images show the driver's side
window was up how could he be reaching
into the car if the windows up and
there's blood on the glass according to
kotv tulsa CBS affiliate a police
sergeant said officers found a vial of
the hallucinogenic drug PCP inside
crushers vehicle along with his wallet
and schoolbooks Scott Wood who is
representing officer Betty Shelby said
Monday she pulled the trigger in fear
for her life it went from hey man is
this your car all the way up to
literally screaming at him to stop what
he was doing while the Department of
Justice has opened a civil rights
investigation over allegations of
excessive force officer Shelby is on
paid administrative leave
protesters at police headquarters said
the policing was alarming I sold hurts
my soul hurts that's why I'm here
justice it's not right we saw the tape
everyone saw take none of the police
officers wore body cameras that day the
Tulsa Police Department did receive
nearly six hundred thousand dollars in
federal grants earmarked for body
cameras last year but the department
still doesn't have them Nora all right
man well thank you